Lars has an announcement to make let's
not [ __ ] around Mars you're going to
forget what you came on to say this is a
beautiful Guy come on well just being
able to share this moment with you and
Robin and the rest of your crew I mean
you guys have been so supportive uh of
Metallica for for decades and we've had
what three or four great shows with you
and playing and and all that that great
stuff so we've been working on a new
album for the last year year and a half
a covert lockdown record and the one
thing that we've done all through that
is is for the first time in our career
we've never really talked about it so
rather than hey there's a new record and
countdowns and guess what's coming your
way and all that kind of [ __ ] we've been
tight [ __ ] lipped about it and this
morning I want to share a new song with
the world and and I want to tell
everybody a fabulous the new Metallica
album and we have a new tour we have a
song we have a video we [ __ ] all the
bells and whistles and we thought for
sure this thing would leak it hasn't
[ __ ] leaked and uh so there's a new
Metallica song We're announcing a new
album that's coming in April of next
year we're announcing a two-year World
Tour we have all the dates for 23 and 24
ready to go we're coming to a city near
here we're playing two nights in every
city playing two completely different
shows so you buy one ticket for two
shows a Friday and a Sunday and you get
what's called a no repeat weekend which
obviously is an old radio term you get
two 100 completely different and unique
shows you know I heard this last night
they said hey Lars has a new I said
really I haven't heard anything about
this is a new Metallica song I said oh
[ __ ] I hope it doesn't suck because what
am I gonna do meanwhile this song is
Beautiful this is a great [ __ ]
Metallica song you want to introduce
this I'll play yeah yeah so it's called
Luxy Luxy Turner what which basically
means Eternal Light it's Latin for for
Eternal Light Luxe Eterna ah it's
beautiful Luxy Turner
listen to this
is a workout brother
[Music]
holy Mackle
listen to those drums show up
[Music]
all right
the new Metallica album is called 72
Seasons that's coming out April 14th
that's the number one thing I want to
mention also thank you Metallica's M72
World Tour now what that means is
tickets go on sale this Friday at 9 00
a.m at ticketmaster.com and these
[ __ ] in concert I have seen
Metallica several times in concert the
band didn't even give me free tickets I
had to pay for them I went it was
mind-blowing
foreign